I ran into somebody there day that I
really respect and he said I'm gonna say
his name but he says he met a girl we're
talking about he's like he's in love and
stuff and then we were talking about it
and he goes um I go are you in love he's
like I'm in love and then he goes I go
how old is she because he's 50 he goes
he's 20 - that is it fresh right fresh
breath I go you wanna date her I like
being serious I think he's here although
not this friend though no no we're
talking he's running 50 minutes so he's
wondering 50 minutes like perfect it's
okay buddy you don't have to come it's
okay buddy so he goes are you gonna have
babies he goes she can't have one I go
what accident was born that way no she
goes no she has a penis because he had
showed me a photo of her before and she
was hot mm-hmm like stunning like a body
her body in her face I'll be honest with
you I got a little a little aroused a
little bit mm-hmm I feel like that's
your dream situation a hot chick with a
dick I feel like I'm kind of close
because I have like a jawline of a man
so I have do dish androgynous features
and I have a flat chest when I had big
breasts you were like your [ __ ] I suck
it like a dick full hands with the boy
he does it's like going up and down you
do do that don't I actually yeah in a
book you're supposed to do that yes when
I read - right - yeah act like you're
sucking a dick
so all those young guys out there do
that yeah I just do that do that yes no
I don't I'm not into that but what the
way he was describing it I was just like
if I wasn't with Kailah and this person
was super like we hit it off and I
didn't know
I would I wouldn't do it before and if I
knew like if the first line is I have a
dick like I like on some sort of like
dating app or something you know those
messages right yeah but if I she never
said anything and then I took her on a
date and I really liked her a lot
and we were hanging out for weeks and
then one day she just says I have a dick
I think that you would be okay with that
my parents wouldn't be that's what I
would think you would know the heron's
dum-dum you don't tell your prince about
her [ __ ] you just adopt a kid that's a
happy and then know if I got mom don't
you love sandy oh cool I like her and
I'd be like here's a dick Oh like I
don't know what would happen yeah I
think my dad will die no you would I
reckon are there no I mean would you
date a chick with a dick George no why
what if you got to know her for like
three months what I'm saying and you're
really starting to fell in love with her
nah just too weird what do you mean I
don't want to have a family at some
point you know yeah yeah adopt things
like the way better what if there's a
technology by then where you can use
both your sperms that's transferred
through your butts and you can have a
child answer it now still no but I don't
have a good reason political right yeah
I bet your money it's religious right um
I've got some still some things from our
religious I know I know you do but you
know my I went to Ibiza with a three of
my guy friends and one of my guy friends
came home at five in the morning we all
shared an apartment with the hottest
tallest blonde this chick and I was like
whoa he never usually pulls girls like
this and he was all excited and then
they walk over to the bathroom I'm
sleeping in the living room couch they
walk over to the bathroom you know they
turned the lights on two minutes later
turned the lights off he escorts her
back to
door and he waves and he says goodbye I
was like dude what happened and he's
like I don't want to talk about it
I don't want to talk about it yeah the
next morning he tells us he's like I'm
so confused because I was fingering her
all night on the dance floor and then
when I went back to the bathroom where
there she had a dick I was like I think
he doesn't know where the [ __ ] loci
he was very drunk and here everyone was
on the field
yeah yeah number water why is it so dry
number two one really tight butt vagina
yeah the [ __ ] were very tight yeah
also why is your large clumps of [ __ ] oh
it's fine fine yeah that's weird that's
a really weird but beautiful beautiful
chick though I'm telling you guys I was
like whoa she's hot you know what I
would do is I would do I would probably
just go okay let's say you're the girl
and what's I know like we've we dated a
couple weeks and I don't like the voice
sorry I'll change the bar I hate that
voice right and um we're making out
just we're making out that's probably
you have to stop right and just tell me
tell me that you're a guy okay let's
make some we're making out all right
Bobby Lee yeah I have to tell you
something what is it
don't freak out I'm not gonna freak out
just don't look at me I'm looking at you
lolly come my tits I love them now look
at me I love it don't freak out I'm not
gonna freak out I'm gonna lower my pants
a little bit okay does it okay
[ __ ] freak out okay you like me right
my personality I love everything about
you my soul I think we're so limited
I'll come glad you said that show you
yeah show me and I'm pulling my pants
down and I see it now I see it right I
want this what I'd say pull it back up
okay right let's make out no no I'm
gonna erase everything you said but the
last ten seconds and just suck my day
yeah and so I'm gonna pretend I never
hurt that part I get my dick song if I
was okay not tell everyone yeah I'll
tell everyone even if they find out she
never told me I never saw a dick you
ever said anything you just said ten
minutes ago that you would definitely
date a chick with a dick yeah I think
that's how I would do it I think yeah
yeah yeah
I would like block it out of my mind
interesting would you know you would
never do it I'd be like why would you
deceive me
you're very traditional though like one
children and do all that children make
you - no - man I want a [ __ ] lawn I
would have [ __ ] have a baby sir
cupcakes left yeah there are huh all
right let's stop now the stop and I'll
wait
we'll be away from James of ever dance
[Music]